t
auj
donc mon signe jean-jacques
nom de famille guérini mon père il a
fait des recherches un petit peu de
partout un donc j'habitais encore sam il
n'y avait pas d'école pour sourds donc
on me proposait la menuiserie
l'électricité et donc j'ai réussi mon
dieu mon cap2 plombier après j'ai appris
sur fassis après j'ai appris une
électricité générale est donc en touche
et 14 diplôme et j'ai travaillé donc à
la réunion ii en tant que professeur
spécialisé pour les sourds mais ben
j'étais toujours passionné 1 par la
céramique par eux par la porte par la
peinture donc j'ai
réussi j'ai obtenu mon diplôme
et aux beaux-arts là j'ai décidé en 2007
de créer ma propre entreprise en tant
qu'artisans à la réunion est là et j'ai
eu beaucoup de monde qui sont venus donc
des personnes sous 1 j'ai décidé de en
parallèle avec ma femme de créer le
centre de formation professionnelle avec
l'éducation nationale pour obtenir un
diplôme en décoration céramique ben le
résultat était positif
il y à issy donc écosse méthodes qui
sont différentes ça veut dire la
première méthode
évincé le moule pour fabriquer des
bonnes des assiettes
des plats festonné
le désastre est moderne mais là avec le
2ème moule donc il ya eu deux parties et
ensuite une partie au niveau de la tâche
justement pour que l'effet soit le piège
de cannes est donc troisième méthode il
ya aussi le tournage donc ça c'est pour
la production donc moulage foulage
tournage et
donc tout est fait à la main à 100% donc
modelage les oxydes safia de réchy
du métal
dont il peut se transformer d'autres y
ait vraiment ce soit très bien et j'ai
calculé qui libre et qu' elle par contre
les emos et rami
ça vient de la roche
donc à moi de métal mais les oxydes
ajouté ce qui est très très fort c'est
ce que ça donne beaucoup d'effet et son
fils mais il faut faire très attention à
une journée de la pesée des cram comme
vous voyez ça ça change la vie on voit
les différentes parties dont on aperçoit
les réseaux mais après passer au four
toutes les couleurs vont ressortir
la manipulation le modelage et à qui
tout cela au bout de 24 mois j'ai obtenu
mon diplôme
et en plus bas le centre m'a embauché et
maintenant je suis devenu responsable
d'atelier séverine elle un métier
passionnant et pour moi tu continues et
là dedans instruments gifle hommes on
serait vraiment
une réussite vraiment d'avoir abouti à
ce projet là bon ben ça c'est mon
objectif qui plus à prendre justement le
métier qu'ils puissent obtenir leur
diplôme beginning qui ne reste pas au
niveau du chômage qui puisse travailler
est facile trouvent pas de travail eux
ils peuvent créer aussi leurs propres
ateliers en tant qu'artisans moi pour
l'instant je montre mon modèle voilà et
je montre aussi mon modèle aux personnes
sauf que les sourds sont capables de
travailler sont capables de tout faire
et jamais été scolarisé de ma vie la
première fois j'ai trouvé donc du
travail ici j'avais vraiment très très
très peur quand j'ai appris le métier on
m'a formé et maintenant je travaille
avec des enfants avec des personnes
handicapées voilà j'ai fait beaucoup
d'accompagnement auprès des personnes
handicapées
voilà je suis sourd mais je travaille
et c'est ce que j'aime c'est le pouvoir
donner mon savoir et de leur transmettre
pour l'avenir ici on me valides et non
valides ensemble et la communication se
passe très bien avec le groupe de
malentendants et nous on a fait quand
même du beau travail